y vamos con nuestra revista de prensa en
directo América y para ello me acompaña
Rosa Pérez más deu Rosa Buen día para
usted Buen día Ángela bueno Rosa el tema
de hoy nos habla acerca de un texto del
New York Times Qué es lo que está
pasando allá arriba teorías pero no
respuestas a la aparición de estos
objetos que han sido derribados en
Norteamérica efectivamente no así como
bien dices teoría teorías pero no
respuestas Y así precisamente arranca
este artículo no del New York Times dice
si la verdad está ahí fuera aún no Es
evidente no y señala que tanto el
pentágono como la inteligencia
estadounidense intentan dar sentido a
estos tres objetos voladores no
identificados por llamarlos de algún
modo que recordemos que aviones de
combate estadounidenses derribaron el
viernes el sábado y el domingo cuando
estos objetos sobrevolaban Alaska Canadá
y Michigan bien dice todo este episodio
suscita no dos preguntas en primer lugar
qué son estas naves que se están
identificando y derribando y por otro
lugar porque parece que Estados Unidos
está detectando y derribando estas naves
recientemente más a que en lo que venía
siendo habitual bien respecto a la
primera pregunta No empecemos por aquí
por qué son estas naves dice New York
Times evidentemente no hay respuesta de
momento tanto el FBI como la real la
policía montada de Canadá están
examinando los restos que han caído al
suelo tras que después de que estos
objetos hayan sido derribados bien en
todo caso recordemos que como decíamos
en los noticieros la alarma y como la
curiosidad alrededor de todo este
episodio aumentó cuando en una rueda de
prensa El general glenban una rueda de
prensa el domingo respondió a la
pregunta de un periodista sobre si había
descartado orígenes extraterrestres de
estos objetos con un no hemos descartado
nada sin embargo un alto funcionario la
seguridad nacional citado en este
artículo del New York Times señaló que
nadie piensa que sean otra cosa que
dispositivos creados aquí en la tierra y
de momento las líneas de investigación
van más bien por ahí Bueno pero es que
ya pasó a otro tono este tema de los
globos o de los objetos voladores usted
me respondió la primera pregunta ahora
la segunda es qué respuesta da New York
Times a la segunda porque parece que
Estados Unidos está detectando y
derribando más objetos y más
recientemente en sus cielos Exactamente
no una pregunta que se podría Traducir
por realmente hay más objetos voladores
de este tipo últimamente en los cielos
estadounidenses o simplemente se están
detectando más no estamos prestándoles
más atención bien no está claro señala
el New York Times Pero lo que sí Es
evidente es que a raíz del episodio no
que desató Este supuesto globo espía
chino no detectado a principios de
febrero el ejército Estados Unidos y de
Canadá está agudizando su vigilancia no
de esos espacios aéreos respectivos tal
y como señaló Melissa daltons o
secretaria de defensa El Comando defensa
aeroespacial de América del Norte norat
afinó su sistema de radar y como
resultado empezó a aumentar la cantidad
de objetos que se detectan no sin
embargo unas fuentes que no acaban de
estar identificadas en este artículo de
New York Times señalan los funcionarios
de estado estadounidenses no descartan
que haya más objetos también en términos
absolutos En todo caso la teoría que más
respalda este artículo es que estos
objetos habrían sido lanzados al espacio
aéreo estadounidense y canadiense por
china u otra potencia extranjera para
probar las capacidades de detección del
ejército y de la inteligencia
estadounidenses no una constatación en
la que coincide Luis Elizondo Quien
dirigió el programa ufo ovni del
pentágono hasta 2000 17 él dice durante
años las potencias rivales han enviado
aparatos de baja tecnología los cielos
estadounidenses pero ahora están usando
aparatos también de baja gama para
acosarnos es una manera de alto impacto
y bajo coste para China para y Cuanto
más mires al cielo más verás Pues bueno
veremos que sigue pasando no cada día
sale una noticia nueva de este tema y en
todo caso Ángela parece que lo que Es
evidente Es que este episodio va a dañar
todavía no las relaciones ya desgastadas
entre Beijing y Washington otro episodio
más ahora vamos a pasar a un tema
completamente distinto y es un tema de
alegría para los estadounidenses el
Super Bowl Pero además hay otra cara y
es el negocio publicitario no que sigue
creciendo Pese a que la audiencia va en
caída efectivamente Y en esto se centra
este artículo de Forbes que señala que
el precio de este año por unos 30
segundos de espacio publicitario en la
Super Bowl ha llegado a superar los
siete millones de dólares no y
precisamente tal y como dice
vicepresidenta de marketing de frito ley
de pepsico parece que no haya límite a
la cantidad de dinero que las marcas
están dispuestas a pagar para estar
presentes en este espacio de medio
tiempo no de esta competición de fútbol
americano en todo caso lo que centra la
atención de este artículo vamos a verlo
con una gráfica muy rápidamente es que a
pesar que bueno que reduzca el número de
audiencia Cada año los precios para
estar presentes en este espacio
publicitario aumentan lo que al final
acaba suponiendo que para las marcas es
más caro digamos llegar a un solo
espectador No de hecho tal y como vemos
aquí en 1993 cada dólar invertido en un
anuncio alcanzaba unas 52 personas en
2016 esta este dólar invertido alcanzaba
unas 21 personas y en 2022 unas 15
personas rápidamente por qué aún así las
marcas continúan queriendo estar
presentes en la superball bueno dicen a
distintas Fuentes este artículo
básicamente Porque estos anuncios son
muy eficaces queremos verlos no no
queremos reunirlos como suele pasar con
la publicidad y por la vanidad de las
marcas no dicen las superball es como el
baile de graduación ante Estados Unidos
todas las marcas quieren estar presentes
de hecho las tres marcas que más han
invertido en la historia en sus anuncios
de la Super Bowl según Univision fueron
coca-cola En tercer lugar Pepsi en
segundo el primero es una cuestión de
privilegio para ellos Gracias